Kim Kardashian is a vision in white on  the cover of wonderland magazine I'm  really excited the 35 year old reality  star graces their autumn 2016 fashion  issue where she opens up about her  interest in becoming a lawyer she tells  mag quote if things slow down and I had  time I really want to go to law school  just something I can do in my older age  though Kim would have to get her  undergraduate degree first as she didn't  attend college after high school it was  really tough for me the mother-of-two  also opened up about her husband Kanye  West's feud with Taylor Swift over his  famous lyrics admitting she meant no  shade after leaking the recorded phone  calls on her snapchat between the 1989  singer and her hubby she told the mag  quote I never publicly talked bad about  people I still don't feel like I have  I'm being honest I'm a fan I like her  music there was no shade oh definitely  definitely  you